حديث نوفاك وهو نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسي
عن مركز توزيع الغاز ياتي بعد ايام من
اتصال هاتفي للرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان مع نظيره الروسيب لا ديمر بوتين
بحث خلاله بحثا خلاله المصالح المشتركه في
مجال الطاقه
ومقترحه انشاء مركز اقليميا لتصدير الغاز
في اسطنبول
استغلال الموقع الاستراتيجيه للبلد بين
اوروبا واسيا الوسطى والشرق الاوسط لتحويل
تركيا الى حلقه وصل بين مصدري الغاز
ومستهلكيه
الان وقد يتوقفت امدادات الغاز الروسي
لاوروبا عبر انابيب نور الشريف واحد
واثنان مازالت كميات اقل تصل عبر الانابيب
العابره الى القاره الاوروبيه من اوكرانيا
ومن بلغاريا كذلك تقدر باقل من عشره في
المئه مما تستهلكه دول القاره
جمع الرئيس التركيه بالرئيس التنفيذي
لشركه غاز بروما الروسيه
لنقل الغاز الروسي عبر تركيا الى القارات
الاوروبيه
وينظر منفوض سياسه الخارجيه للاتحاد
الاوروبي يجوز البوريني او بعين الريبه
الى هذا التقارب بالتركيه الروسيه قال ان
عدم استعداد تركيا للانضمام الى العقوبات
الغربيه على روسيا هو مدعاته للقلق